In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen."
The reading from the Sinek Sadion from A3rd, on which we commemorate, are venerable Father
Theodosius, abbot of the Lavra, of the Kiev Caves, and founder of the Cenabetic Life in
Russia.
Our Holy Father Theodosius was born in Vasilyev, a town near Kiev of Christian parents who
then moved to Kursk.
From his childhood, he fled from laughter and play to dedicate himself to the recitation
of the Scriptures and to prayer.
Thirteen years old when his father died, he undertook to lead a life in more rigorous
conformity to the teaching of the gospel.
Desirous of imitating the Lord, he abased himself to the state of a slave.
He went to work in the fields with the servants and willingly made himself the lowest of all.
His mother was greatly angered by this conduct and considered that he was thus casting
discredit on his line by mixing with men of low degree.
Despite repeated correction, Theodosius' spirit remained no less attached to the care of
pleasing God and he nourished the ardent desire to make a pilgrimage to the holy places.
He once left the family home at night to follow a group of pilgrims who were going to the
holy land.
As soon as she became aware of his flight, his mother set out in pursuit.
Having caught up with them, she grabbed her son by his hair after having kicked him, took
him back home like a criminal.
Theodosius promised not to leave her again as long as he could work on the salvation of his
soul and took up his devotions again, attending the liturgy daily and baking the prosphoda
himself.
After some time, fearful of the ralery of their neighbors, his mother wanted to forbid
him to lower himself thus to the work of baking.
But Theodosius showed her with the help of passages from Holy Scripture that there was no more
noble activity than the preparation of the offerings for the Holy Sacrifice, and she left him
in peace.
A year later, persecution and ill-treatment once more began against the servant of God
and his mother bullied him still more violently when she found the iron belt that he wore around
his body and which left blood stains on his shirt.
Finally, at the age of 23, in 1032, he fled on foot towards Kiev and guided by God, arrived
at the cave where St. Antony lived.
Following at the elder's feet in tears, he begged him to receive him as a disciple.
Antony tried at first to dissuade the young nobleman, making the difficulties of such a way of
life clear to him.
But seeing his ardent love of God, he accepted him and told St. Nikon to clothe him in the
holy angelic habit.
Theodosius immediately embarked on great spiritual striving, fasting strictly, and keeping
vigil all night through.
When his mother found him after a long search and asked to see him, theodosius refused to
receive her.
When she threatened that she would kill herself on the spot, he went out of the cave and said
to her,
Mother, if you want to see me again, stay in Kiev and take the veil and one of the woman's
monasteries in the town.
You can thus work out your salvation.
Having at first violently opposed this, she then realized the vanity of the things of
the world and became a nun in the monastery of St. Nicholas and Kiev, where she entered into
rest.
After St. Nikon's departure, St. Theodosius was ordained priest for the community which
then comprised twelve monks with St. Barlem as their abbot.
They lived a very hard life, working with their hands and praying without ceasing.
In the mornings they gathered in their makeshift chapel for the office.
Then went to work for a time or read before the liturgy.
After having eaten a little dry bread, they took up their work again in silence until Vespers.
Theodosius surpassed all the brethren, not only in his ascetic labors, but especially in
his gentleness and brotherly love.
He often spent whole nights in prayer or read the Psalter in the open air, impervious to
the mosquito bites and only rested sitting on a chair.
On other occasions, when the other monks were sleeping, he ground grain to save them trouble
and was the first in church at dawn and the last to leave it.
When St. Barlem was transferred to another monastery, the brethren unanimously chose
Theodosius to direct them under the paternal guidance of St. Antony.
The community grew rapidly at that time and it became necessary to build more cells and
a church a short distance from the caves.
Thanks to the help of Vesia Slav Jato Slavic, Prince of Kiev, the enterprise succeeded well
and the new monastery was inaugurated in 1062.
It was, however, no longer possible to preserve for this important community, the freedom
and flexibility of life enjoyed by the first group of ascetics in the cave.
A synabetic rule of life was necessary.
Because of this, St. Theodosius enjoined on the monk Ephrem, who was going on a pilgrimage
to the holy places and to Constantinople to make himself familiar with the usage of the
Byzantine monasteries and to take a copy of the tipicon of the famous monastery of the
studio in back to Russia.
The monastery of the Kiev caves kept the title of Lavra in memory of the semi-erimetic grouping
that first came together round St. Antony, but it later became known as Sinovium, a faithful
inheritor of Byzantine monasticism that was to serve as a prototype for other Russian
monasteries down the ages.
Good order and harmony reigned there, making the monastery an image of the kingdom of heaven
and a model of life for all who are friends of virtue.
Prince Isia Slav had a great veneration for St. Theodosius and often visited him to ask his
advice.
One day, when he arrived after the doors had been shut, the porter refused to open to him
saying that the abbot had given orders to open to no one after nightfall, even if a prince
were in question.
He therefore left the sovereign outside and went to inform the abbot.
This episode greatly edified the prince, who, far from being angry, showed an even greater
respect for St. Theodosius and his monastery.
When Prince Svyatislav, of Chernikov, drove his brother Isia Slav from the throne of Kiev,
St. Theodosius reproached him openly for his action and refused to commemorate the usurper
in the litany.
During the great fast, it was a saint's custom to withdraw to the cave where they had begun
their ascetic life, and he only reappeared on the Friday before Great Week to instruct the
brethren.
In the cave he endured many attacks by the demons, but courageously repulsed them with
fasting and prayer, and emerged in triumph to celebrate the Lord's resurrection.
He taught preeminently by his example, often working himself in the bakery or the kitchen,
and undertaking without complaint work that the other brethren had refused to do.
If he learned that the meal had been prepared without the abbot's usual blessing, or if
a quarrel had broken out over its preparation, he ordered that all the food be thrown into
the fire.
If, when visiting the monks' cells he found unnecessary articles, money or food, he burned
them at once, reminding them that a true monk must possess nothing of his own.
St. Theodosius also showed great love for the poor, and had a hostilery built near the monastery
where they could lodge all the needy who went there.
Every Saturday the saint sent a boatload of bread to those held in Kiev's prisons.
Having acquired great favor with God through his charity and perseverance and prayer, he drove
out unclean spirits, healed serious illness, and was given the gift of prescience.
One night some thieves came to steal precious objects from the church, but every time they
went up to it they were held back by angelic voices from inside, which they believed to
be those of the monks.
When the monks arrived to celebrate the office in the morning, the thieves tried to rush
into the church and massacre them, but to their stupification they suddenly saw the church
rising into the air.
They fled, and, sometime later, their chief and three of his companions came to ask the
saints forgiveness and to tell them what had happened, and none of the monks had witnessed
the miracle.
As the community continued to grow, St. Theodosius prayed that God would permit the enlargement
of the monastery on the building of a stone church.
A short time afterwards, four Greek builders from Constantinople arrived at the monastery,
saying that they had been employed by the mother of God herself to build the church, of which
she had shown them a model in a vision.
They were carrying with them relics of the holy martyrs to be placed in the foundations,
and a miraculous icon of the all-holy.
The site having been revealed by God, they measured the proportions of the building using
a golden girdle given by Prince Simon of the Vorangians, and it was Prince Sviati Slav
of Kiev who himself began the digging of the foundations.
In the same year, 1073, St. Antony gave his soul into God's hands, and a year later, God
revealed to Theodosius that he would soon leave this world.
The holy abbot summoned the brethren and asked them to choose his successor.
St. Stephen, having been elected, Theodosius gave him his blessing, gave a fatherly embrace
to each brother, and then fell asleep in peace in 1074.
The tomb of the holy founder of Russian-Senobitic monasticism later became a source of miracles.
Prince Antony and Theodosius never ceased watching over the monastery, and ten years later,
they appeared to iconographers in Constantinople to order them to go and adorn the church
of the Lavra, which once finished was blessed in 1089 by Metropolitan John of Kiev.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.